okay um good evening everybody and
welcome to this evening's meeting
planning and development management
committee um just by way of
introductions my name is aiden williams
i'm the chair of the committee also
present tonight are offices from the
council's planning service legal service
democratic service and highway authority
local highway authority
as well as the elected councillors who
sit on the committee to make
determinations this evening
um just turning to the agenda the first
item is attendances oh i should also
note just referee's information that
this meeting has been recorded it's also
been live streamed on the council's
website facility
um so the first item of business this
evening is to note attendances we've
received apologies from councillor
chalkin who i believe is being
substituted by councillor button thank
you and also from councillor
um
council hassan who's been substituted by
councillor acton thank you and and then
lastly from councillor hartley as well
couldn't join us tonight
um item number two is declarations of
interest are there any members
to make a declaration of interest ms
kotlin
thank you chairman i'd like to declare
an interest in the application at 208 to
210 most lane i'll be leaving the room
during the consideration of the item and
i can confirm i've had no input into the
report before members this evening thank
you
thank you um council morgan
thank you chair um i've got two i've got
one which i'm i will be leaving the room
for which is 18 finchdale drive um i've
had representations with the
owners about the
application which has been decided by
the inspector although that's not this
application i think i i um to be correct
i think i should be leaving the room for
that and for fun for fund and drive the
applicant is um the son of the um one of
the councillors in our group um i don't
think that we've got an overriding in um
need to
yeah start again i don't think um i
think we can um
retain a level of independence on that
judgment but i think i just want to put
it on the record that that item and i
think i probably speak for the other
conservative members on that
thank you for councillor whiting
on that uh
founding drive that one could just seek
a legal uh officer's view on on that i
do know
the applicant i don't know him well
um
and i just want to be uh clear in you
know today's uh observing of things um
quite where we stand in terms of
declaring interests
um that would be up to the individual
councillor to consider whether he thinks
that
interest is going to affect his judgment
on the matter so as long as you're
of the view that it doesn't then um
you're able to remain in the room and
vote
okay i'm i'm
grateful for you clarifying that that
helps me thank you
councillor minis
um for 217 woodhouse lane east oh on
because i have been involved in it um
previously so i'll take myself out the
written thank you councillor hunting
yes same as the
two conservative members obviously it's
the son of the leader the conservative
group is for page 72
so i'll be making the same declaration i
don't feel it will affect my vote in any
way but just for a public record uh make
that declaration
thank you okay
um thank you for those item number three
is minutes which have been circulated
prior to the meeting
members happy you can see council thomas
moving to accept those minutes members
happy to support that
it's what take those is kevin thank you
um item number four is questions members
of the public haven't been notified of
any questions haven't been received
prior to the meeting
item number five is the additional
information report which has been
circulated to members via email earlier
today there are also paper copies here
tonight
and item number six is applications for
permission to develop um the first
application that we'll consider is
application 106 946 18 finch hail drive
in hail which can be found on page 64 of
the committee report
um
before we turn to discussion the
application will be introduced by mr day
thank you chair
so the first application before members
this evening relates to 18 inch hail
drive a detached bungalow on the north
side of the road
the application proposes the erection of
a single story side extension
previous to the current application an
application for prior approval was
submitted in 2021
that proposed the erection of an
additional story to the existing
dwelling
that application was submitted under
class a a of the town and country
planning act for prior approval this
application was refused by traffic
council
but following an appeal by the applicant
the planning inspector did grant consent
for that in january 2022
the current application
relates solely to the side extension
as originally submitted this application
did seek
approval for the additional story and
the side extension
however following a conversation with
the case officer who informed them that
this would not be possible and to
amalgamate both planning permission and
prior approval and that the
additional story wouldn't be acceptable
under planning permission that element
of the application of the application
was withdrawn from the current proposal
therefore the current proposal relates
solely to the single-story side
extension
eight objections have been received from
neighbours along finchdale drive and on
robin drive along with an objection from
councillor bert
whilst the objections receive relate
primarily to the
additional story
objections have also been received in
relation to the current proposal in
relation to its design and scale
and impact on the surrounding area
the single story extension is considered
to be of an appropriate scale and design
and complementary to the character of
the existing bungalow
whilst we do understand the concerns of
residents in relation to the first
follow that does not form part of this
current proposal and that has been
relayed to the applicant
therefore judging the application solely
on its merits of the proposal we are
recommending approval
thank you
thank you ms milner and there were two
speakers wishing to speak against this
application counselor butt and dr el
cafari and have you determined you'd
like to speak first
hi thanks for joining us um you can just
make sure that the microphones on it
should sort of glow red and green and
then you've got three minutes to speak
if you want to over time a little bit
i'll just politely ask you to wrap up
your contribution yeah i'm afraid i'm
faster i understood you thank you
difficult to speak
very quickly okay thank you very much
my name is dr alcafrary my mother owns
20 finchel drive immediately next door
to the proposed development
i'm speaking on behalf of my mother and
the many neighbors on our street and
also
joining the proper near the prophecy
who have strongly objected this
development
as the committee will know the applicant
for over a year now and has been very
briefly outlined not in an awful lot of
detail
but he's me the applicant has made five
different
um
africa uh planet plans three with three
separate publications but five sets of
different plans
he's persistently sought to develop a
two-story megabuild
on the cul-de-sac that is comprised of
purely bungalows there are no other
houses on that street and there are many
other developments all very considerate
of the neighbours and well within the
planning guidance of trafford council
i think there's two important things i'd
like to raise please
firstly
the current application
we do think do not think it should be
approved in its current format it will
significantly block light to
twenty-fifth shell drives east facing
kitchen window
the proposed side return with a massive
west facing apex roof
will result in significant overshadowing
and should be modified to a much lower
pitch
the side return also runs just one meter
away from the boundary
the 2012 traffic guidelines on
extensions warns against this
i quote
an extension positioned too close to a
boundary may cause a loss a loss of
sunlight and or daylight to a neighbor's
window or garden
care should be taken that the extension
is not positioned in such a way as to
cause
unreasonable overshadowing of a
neighboring house
sadly we do not believe
care has been taken
with regard to the sunlight
my mother who's lived in her bungalow
now for over 20 years is extremely
distressed she's in her 80s and is
extremely distressed with the impending
loss
of morning sunlight from her kitchen
window
and the visual aspect of an overbearing
overshadowing
incredibly close wall and roof structure
i therefore ask the committee to refuse
to grant permission for the development
in its current form
secondly i'll just quickly the history
has already been given so i'll skip the
history and go now to the
um
the application as it stands
so the applications it stands
uh in january 22
uh the applicant
submitted the present application which
incredulously as pointed out initially
was in the original format that was
refused
uh that is a first story
and a side return but as pointed out
it was suggested that would be refused
and so it was removed but i think
crucially here incredibly crucially if i
could please
raise um this as a concern
the extremely large hallway has been
retained as in the original plan
and the concern of
all of us collectively
is that
this is where the original plan
staircase to the second floor is to be
installed
so our real concern
is that in the future if this proposal
is allowed in the current design
if it's approved a subsequent
application will be submitted seeking to
build a second story in the future
at which point the council may be
severely limited in its powers to say no
as it did previously
and it may be limited
based on the class aaa permitted
development
rules that recently were
came into play
this would effectively result
in
the traffic council's initial refusal
being thwarted
and the building would be erected as
originally planned a year ago
[Music]
and
this of course is of great concern
and so finally
a couple of very tiny points finally
firstly i would kindly ask the committee
to consider imposing conditions
firstly
on the current proposal to prevent the
loss of sunlight on my mother's property
and secondly that the committee does
whatever is within its powers
to order
within his powers in order to place
robust conditions restricting further
development in the future
and thus creating the original build
that was refused a year ago
finally i would like to point out
that
i think all of us residents on the
street
would be happy with an extension it was
in keeping with the excellent trafford
council guideline guidance
as all the other bungalows on the street
there are several ones have been
developed none of them have done other
within the council guidelines thank you
very much thank you doctor olga farwey
um councillor book do you like to
just come and sit there in front of the
microphone
you've got five minutes to speak counsel
if you do one overtime i'll just ask you
to wrap up thank you thank you very much
chair um
the the the objections have been
eloquently put by the the previous
speaker so i'll keep mine reasonably
short though i mean this application has
been a source of great concern to their
neighboring properties and the majority
of residents on finch hale drive
i make reference to para126 of the nppf
which has been quoted by about good
design making development acceptable to
communities
this is clearly not the case for
residents living on finch hill drive in
this case
because of the proposed plans
incompatibility with the surrounding
properties and character of the area the
neighboring residents do not regard it
as meeting the standards within policy
seven of the core strategy
this application
needs to be revised to provide more
specific detail regarding its height and
footprint and provide a more acceptable
plan for neighbouring properties i would
therefore request that it be refused in
its current form
thank you chair
thank you councillor um are there any
members wishing to open the discussion
location
thank you chairman um
[Music]
i can very easily sympathise with the
viewpoints put forward by dr farri and
but and i take their points on board um
i do have concerns as was pointed out
that this is perhaps uh
although it's
the the intention may be to combine this
with future works in terms of the design
that's been put forward as doctor olgari
stated however that would require a
future planning permission and we can't
obviously
uh
you know restrict or prevent a future
planning committee from from acting in
the way that it it decides to at the
time
if we were talking about a two-story
building or two-sided extension then i
accept that uh that would be
unacceptable i agree with the previous
decision made and i uh respectfully
disagree with the uh appeal decision
um
however we are now talking about the
single side extension only we're not
talk and as it's been pointed out by the
officers that cannot be combined with
the
with you know previous decisions
and and justify to store build
i do have concerns
regarding the uh
height of the
roof uh in relation to the single story
however and i think it may cause some
overshadowing however i'm not sure if
that alone is sufficient to refuse the
application uh as stated by the officers
so therefore i'm very much in two minds
on this one as we stand at the moment
and i look for as why i was waiting
before i spoke originally to see what
other members of this committee might
have to say about it
uh so i'm not going to make any proposal
at this stage
uh i i'm going to listen to what other
members of this committee might have to
say but i am
very sympathetic to the to the
objectives um however i have concerns
regarding the robustness of a refusal if
we were to try and make one
um and so i will wait and find out what
my fellow committee members have to say
before i make a final decision
thank you chairman
thank you and councillor
that's one of my concerns as well
bearing in mind that secretary of
state's already overruled and i'm look
i'm looking at the right one
and where does that bear any relation
with this set of plans because it was a
set of plans that we disregarded and
didn't appeal against am i mixing up
with someone else
no you're correct so there was a prior
approval
it was refused by officers and the
planning inspector approved it
if this was refused it would be assessed
against the development plan
so it'd be assessed against our policy
and guidance
and it would not be assessed against the
general permitted development order
which the previous application was
right my concerns either i don't want us
ending up having to spend more money
again if we refuse it and they appeal
against
okay councillor winston thank you
uh thank you chair i share many of the
concerns of the previous two speakers um
this feels to me like
someone's salami slashing using the um
using the planning process and just
getting
the bits they think they can get through
individually
i have great sympathy with what the what
the speaker said i wouldn't be ha i
wouldn't be happy with the process
that's being followed
if i lived on this street
however
we're instructed by the planning team
that we have to consider this in
isolation
and if you consider this plan
uh the proposal before in isolation i
also don't think there are robust enough
reasons to
to refuse it
on my previous picks i'll be very
interested to to hear what the rest of
the committee have to say thank you
chair
thank you councillor thomas
thank you chair um
in like the guidance we've been given
and and looking at it whilst it may not
be
the best sighted or situated
extension
in terms of neighbours
there is no reason i can see whatsoever
to
to refuse this
we can't
make a decision that somebody may or may
not be
deciding to put a second story on
or do whatever so i'm quite happy to
propose
the officer's recommendation is accepted
thank you thank you councilman
i have a question um with the roof of
the of the extension
is there any way it can be lower or is
it to do with the pitch of it um needing
to be if you can put a picture up so i
just want
i'm just thinking of how to minimize how
you know because it is close
to the boundary of the neighbour and i
just wanting to see whether there's a
way of making it
less overbearing for them
um
so i'll
so here we have the proposed extension
so the height of the eaves is 2.3 yeah
that's not that's quite modest for a
needs height the maximum height is i
think it's
just over four meters 4.5
and so that is above missing development
rights and if it was lower it would
likely fall it would be moving towards
permitted development and however if it
was reduced in height you would see a
change um in in the pitch so it would it
might result in more of an incongruous
design
and a bit more contrived and that would
be our concerns um but that the 4.5 is
at the pitch it's the maximum height but
adjacent to the boundary is 2.3 so is it
to do is like so when you look at this
obviously from the roadside obviously
we're wanting it to go same angle is
that what is it sort of
the appearance effectively from the road
so it to get the same angle rather than
say at a more
it's a more acute angle
is that the reason if yes so at the
moment you can see the extension to
sorry my curse is not visible but if you
look at the top left-hand side of the
screen you've got the front elevation so
they've sought to kind of um match the
pitch almost if it were to go any lower
it would be um
it probably would result in a contrived
design which we would probably have
concerns about and the impact on the
neighbor in relation to
the boundary and eve's height of less
than 2.3 is not common 2.3 is is a
modest height for a news right okay
that's a thank you thank you for that
thank you
thank you um councillor wetton
uh thank you um
if i'm understanding the preamble of
this correctly the applicant
really is coming from a position of
strength
uh and
in looking at this
report which um it's fairly thin i mean
there's detail there but it's thin i
think that quite clearly our officers
see this as
um a clear case for approval so when i
put those two things together
uh
i see that this is is
something to be
um approved by this uh
by this um council by this uh meeting um
so i think it's been moved so i would i
would second that it is
approved the officer's recommendation
thank you councillor councilwelton
i was basically going to say the same
thing as my namesake uh here and uh i
think
that
i can understand the history
with this application or the previous
application um but i think if this came
before us in its current form
whether it actually reached the
committee or not i'm not certain but i
think you know i don't think we'd have
too much problem with
with granting it in its current form so
i'm happy to back um the motion to grant
okay thank you um i just wanted to
reflect on some of the comments made by
dr el cavalli if possible um it's quoted
from 2002 guidelines i think we just
said
uh what won against expansion extension
boundaries being positioned to cause
overshadowing
um and then we heard from council the
book that he was concerned that it's not
policy l7 play and i think there is
mention in progress 11 and 12 with the
report to sort of
um briefly touch on those issues about
that particular aspect of the extension
the impact on that neighbor it can i
just check is it policy comply
in terms of sbd full which is our
guidance on householder extensions and
provides
more kind of numerical
assessment yes it is compliant it is one
meter from the boundary as
spd4 only requires single-story
extensions to be 0.75 meters from the
boundary it doesn't also go beyond the
rear building line so for yes it is
compliant for us
and i just um if i can and wanted to
reflect on the conditions that were
requested
my understanding would be we couldn't
condition that there couldn't be further
development
or further applications
no you're correct um i have touched upon
this in the additional information
report any um condition
applied by officers has to meet six
tests and one of them is that any
condition must relate to the development
being proposed and a future development
is is a separate matter and it would not
be reasonable so therefore it would not
be a sound planning condition and i
think as previously raised
if there was a future proposal for an
additional story combined with this we
could then assess that separately under
a new application
okay thank you very much um are there
any members
looking to
contribute
i'm sorry drug fighter i can't bring you
back in i don't appreciate you probably
feel strongly on this um
it has been proposed in second did the
the application be granted in line with
office of recommendation and there's no
other members of indicator will take
that to the vote if members happy to
support that can indicate now please
okay i think that's
unanimous that application is approved
thank you everybody
um we'll now turn to application 106 393
90 mossvale road in stratford which can
be found on page 40 of the committee
report
um so this application is going to be
introduced by ms milner sorry
thank you the next application relates
to 90 moss vale road
a semi-attached property in stratford
that has recently been extended
the proposal is for the conversion of
the single dwelling into an 8-bed house
of multiple occupation hmo
the previous extensions include a hip to
gable roof alteration and a rear dormer
which were
constructed under permitted development
when it was a single dwelling this was
followed by a planning application for a
two-story side and rear
extension which was approved and is
currently um on-site it's
been constructed
and these extensions do not form part of
the current application
the current proposal relates solely to
the change of use along with some minor
alterations to windows
four objections have been received from
neighbours along with a call-in from
council accordingly objections relate
both to the previous extensions and to
the change of use with concern over
noise and disturbance the scale and
quality of the hmo and the impact on
parking along with impacts on amenity of
neighbours
the physical alterations proposed are
considered to be minor and not resource
in
a negative impact on residential or
visual amenity
in regards to the proposed hmo and
whilst offices recognize it is a large
property with eight bedrooms
the hmo does propose a good quality of
accommodation with all room sizes
meeting both traffic's hmo policy
standards and the national
national technical space standards in
addition there is
a shared living area a shared kitchen
and dining area
a study area along with three shared
bathrooms
concerns regarding parking and
nuisance have been reviewed by the lha
and environmental protection and neither
raising objections conditions are
proposed to address the concerns in
relation to cycle parking and in
relation to a management plan
therefore subject to the conditions in
the report we do recommend approval
thank you
thank you ms milner and there's two
speakers speaking against this
application um one of the speakers has
submitted a statement so just gotta let
you want to
speak first
yeah thank you
yeah
were you notified you are
um thank you for allowing me to speak um
the application involves a property
built as a three-bed semi
but following permitted development
rights has already been converted to a
six bed
and the application in front of you
increases
it to an eight bed hmo
due to permitted rights
planning committee does not get to see a
huge amount of hmos
this makes this call
calling
even more pertinent
as this application is an example
of the extent to which we're allowing
the squeezing of families into smaller
spaces
your planning report suggests that the
hmo would provide future occupants with
a good standard of living accommodation
with reference to the shared internal
space
with all respect i totally disagree with
that
um if you the ground floor kitchen and
shared living space is now expected to
accommodate
eight
bedrooms which could be eight separate
individual living units
i do not consider
a three a 1950s three bed semi offers a
kitchen that can accommodate that
that that's just my view your
the the regulations may say differently
but my honest human opinion is that that
is wrong
um the original semi is expanding beyond
anything that the original developers
envisaged
residents are concerned about it being
overbearing
i'm concerned too about air quality this
property is right next to the m60 you
could not get nearer to the m60 we're
cramping
eight beds into this household
that like that obviously reduces the
amount of air volume entitled to each
person in the unit
i don't know what effect that has do you
i don't know
um
we rarely talk about sewage but we've
had floods in los stock sewage floods um
not last year but the year before
it's a totally different
premises
converting a three bed semi to eight
beds
um so i hope that the planning committee
will look at this with fresh um eyes
this can well understand the
representations from um
the neighbours
um
i think hmos get waved through
far too easily in my opinion and this is
a good opportunity to pull one apart
because i think eight beds in a three
bed semi is way beyond what is expected
and i also taken
i was really interested in the
additional
information report
basically i disagree with what it says
if this doesn't um if this doesn't alter
the noise and disturbance
dynamics from a family house then i
really would like to see your research
um
thank you thank you for listening thank
you
mr corningly um also we should speak
against the application of mr mrs
chocopoo you've submitted a statement
that will be read out by ms coley
thank you chairman
the the objector is the owner occupier
of 92 mossvale road and the immediate
neighbour of 90 mos vale road sharing
the wall they have the following
concerns about 90 mossville road
the property is a corner plot and there
is space for an extension it is
originally a three-bedroom house and
extending it to an eight bedroom hmo
looks way out of the rules and
regulations i also doubt about the room
sizes and car parking
the set properties in a junction where
there is a primary school nearby and
also a lot of high school students go
past the property
and the above circumstances considering
this property as an eight bedroom hmo
will create problems for the children
and unwanted parking issues near a
crucial junction which might result in
accidents
i could see in the planning portal a
previous application for making the
property a six bedroom for dwelling
purposes whereas all of a sudden this
application is made for an eight bedroom
hmo
from this and under the opinion the
owner made the house an eight bedroom
with six bedroom planning permission
also the planning promotion was issued
to the owner for six bedrooms without
discussing the matter when asked i was
told by the council that if the number
of representations against the approval
or less than six it will be considered
in favor of the application i cannot see
this six representations rule anywhere
could it be mentioned in the letters you
sent out to the neighbours
in my case the previous owner of 92
mossvale road was in a firm opinion of
selling the house and was not at all
bothered about any letters from the
council about the development of 90
mossville road
the previous owner of 92 mossville road
made a representation against
development of 90 mossvale road the
total representations could be six and
the matter could be different altogether
also the dormer on 90 mosfel road is
causing problems for the full potential
of my pv solar panel system in meeting
the required power generation
it needs reshaping so that i could help
the environment by generating more clean
energy thank you
thank you um speaking in favor of the
application is mr shah um thank you for
joining us if you can just make sure the
microphone's on before you speak and
you've got three minutes to
speak to committee thank you
thank you councillors for allowing me
the opportunity to speak today in favor
of the development i wish you take this
chance to give some context to where
this proposal has been put forward
hopefully this might address some of the
concerns in the objections received i
had originally purchased the property
for me my wife and my kids with my
sister who lost her husband a few years
ago once we had found the ideal home we
put forward an application for the side
and rear extension to realize the full
potential of the property
these extensions were granted planning
and we arranged for the building work to
start as soon as possible so we could
move in
unfortunately it was during this time
that my father covered 19 and became
severely ill resulting in
hospitalization for three months since
being discharged his health has never
recovered and he now needs full-time
care my mother also had her own health
issues and suffered a heart attack my
wife and
my wife and i took the decision to stay
with my parents as their living carers
this meant we had to give up our
ambitions to move into 90 mosfet road
and and had to think about some other
way to utilize the property
having already put so much time and
effort into the property
i wanted to keep the property as an
asset that would also be a reminder one
of my first ventures in dealing with
properties and development the idea was
proposed to turn the now six-bedroom
house into an eight-bedroom hmo more and
more people are looking for short-term
rooms to rent in shared houses with all
bills included rather than having to
live alone and pay for a whole house and
so out their own bills it will also
provide a variety of alternative range
of housing opportunities for the area
as part of planning
submission we have been in talks with
the property management company that
also assisted with the submitted
management plan to ensure any concerns
associated with the term hmo can be
addressed accordingly the environmental
protection team have no objections to
the proposals and of us the management
plan is put into practice which
is our intention to do so as part of the
management the neighbors will be given
their contact details so if any issues
do arise they can be dealt with
accordingly and appropriately
highways had no objections unrequested
minor changes which we have also agreed
to there will all there will now be
ample parking and no intrusion on the
public highway it is un anticipated
those that would be renting room
would not necessarily have a private
vehicle since they would most likely
work locally and travel via public
transport we have also discussed the
plans with hmo licensing to ensure we
are meeting the highest standard and
have taken their advice we will be
installing the necessary fire protection
and security measure to ensure a safe
and secure living environment for the
occupants
we hope the new neighbors will also
impose them the same respect that will
be expected of them when they assign the
tenancy agreements
the council have recommended this
application for approval it complies
with the relevant planning policies on
hmo standards we have increased where
possible the communal areas to providing
a comfortable high quality place to live
we hope the community can look favorably
on this application agree
with the planning office's report to
approve thank you for your time
thank you mr shah thanks for that um
with any members wishing to open the
discussion councilwoman stanley
uh thank you chair that's a question to
start off with just some clarification
on the on the report
on page 45 on
section 10
it lists the the numbers of hmos within
a 40 meter
radius
and then in the next paragraph it says
that
those hmos are not included in our hmo
register am i am i reading that
correctly
sorry
that there is no other hmo's right
registered within the 40 meter radius
yes so paragraph 10 says the properties
from the 14
40 meter radius are listed below yep are
they listing hmos
no then
what that was to clarify is the number
of properties we were looking at because
our guidance says 40 meters
but a minimum of 10. so that was to set
out which properties we looked at and to
demonstrate we looked at more than 10
properties and none of them are listed
as hmos
you can tell i'm not quite getting this
uh so they're not actually listed as
hmos they're just the properties within
the 40 meter range yes yes and we wanted
to confirm that that 40 meter radius
also exceeded 10 properties which is
it's 40 meters with a minimum of 10. so
brilliant okay okay thank you for the
clarity
um
and just to continue i'm instinctively
against this i've been watching this
house growing every time i drive to the
um it's on my route from home to the
town hall and i've been watching it grow
to a size which is
i cannot believe it's been allowed to
grow to the size on the um on such a
corner plot
um
i also uh so
it's too big i realize that's not the
issue before the planning committee
today is whether it's allowed to be an
hmo or not
i have great difficulty to believe that
eight individuals living in this is not
going to cause traffic issues i have
great difficulty believing that the
noise generated by an hmo with eight
individual people in it
is the same as that generated by
a single family
um so i am against this in principle
thank you chair
thank you and counselor acton
thank you chair
um
like previous
speakers who spoke against uh this
application
um i feel very strongly against this
development and this change of use
um
this
has been said really um it was a single
dwelling
uh house semi-detached
um which was in keeping
with all the rest of the houses
on that road
and there are you know quite a role in
terms of the semi-detached houses
this now stands out as something
completely
different from what
what was there before and out of
character
in that particular
area
and i recognize that there is permitted
development
but i too have watched this grow
week by week
to be honest to
grow out of control i would have thought
um
and
i
completely
agree
and have great sympathy
for
the person who lives next door to this
property which is it completely over
develops
that
and and
you know stretches over that um property
in my view in terms of light
and
how how it sits
uh as an extension
and it has been permitted so i recognize
that factor
um but it was a single dwelling house it
wasn't a house in multiple
occupation and that does change things
as well um it changes the use completely
it is on a a very bad
bend which has a mini roundabout there
are
two schools that are nearby
on winchester road
there is a lollipop
person who
you know actually
stands there and
you know crosses children over on a
daily basis in quite a difficult area
and i think how people actually access
um
that this particular property will
will be difficult and potentially there
could be eight cars coming out and i
don't know how you would fit eight cars
in there without all of them backing up
and if
if one can't get out the other one would
you know um
would find it very difficult
and there'll be all these maneuvers
around
near to that roundabout
there is overlooking there is
a light that will be
which will be restricted into
uh the next door
don't want i'm really not inclined to
talk to you but i just i suppose i want
to emphasize that the extension's
already been run to permission i know
that right but but what i'm trying to um
articulate really is that this comes on
top of of all that and so that makes it
worse right uh that that's all i'm
saying yeah i just wanted to clarify
remember what we're voting on is
i absolutely do understand that chair
um
and i do feel that there will be extra
noise uh there'll be an extra
disturbance
and there will be um
you know
difficulties on the roads
uh traffic difficulties on the roads so
i think putting all that together
i i would find it very very difficult to
support this application
and will not be supporting it
thank you councillor and councillor
canola
um although i have a lot of sympathy
with the neighbours um
[Music]
it is about a change of use and it is
for hmo and within the rules from what i
can see it's within those
and there's no guarantee that even if it
wasn't permitted as a hmo that the next
family that moved in didn't have more
than eight people living there anyway
and there will be more noise because
there's bound to be with more people but
i'm also very aware that the housing
market the way that it is there are more
people who can't afford to rent a whole
flat or a house and are looking for
rooms
and my other concern is that doing hmos
can sometimes make
accessing housing even more
expensive if people are going into it
just for profit and that does concern me
but
um i can't really see apart from it
being uncomfortable for the neighbours
to have lots of people living next door
which they haven't got any control over
anyway
and as the reason why not to uh to vote
against this
thank you i'm councillor minis
[Music]
um
my main issue is um
turning from a six is i know that the
building is already how it is so you
know that's been gone and it's they're
now the contents of the house as my
understanding and whether it was a six
bed and that now it's being turned into
an eight bed it's the idea of
redistribution of the space so
i mean i think that really um as an
eight bedroom in in reality of of of um
uh having that as an hmo you're going to
have there are going to be certain rooms
where you'll have one person in them and
there's going to be certain rooms in
that house where you're gonna have
couples so you're gonna in reality you
well would you you're shaking your head
is that it's not allowed to it's a
maximum of eight residents
it's a maximum
is that is that a condition that's being
put in okay okay all right okay that's
that's better um i do wonder why why
would why um why h why not six i guess
that's just the application that's been
put forward um is there enough bathroom
i mean we've got obviously the kitchen
diner etcetera downstairs is enough
bathrooms for
eight people in the house um is
is this
i have an issue with it being eight i
have a massive problem with it being
eight it's a three bed semi extended yes
will be it but i have an issue with it
being eight um and i think that it's the
wrong
place i think six yes
i think eight
is is too many really so i'm not in
favor unless i can hear anything that
convinces me the other way now i'm not
i'm not in favour thank you
thank you um
council the dogma
sorry as as quite often i'm probably
going to ask some questions that are not
our remit here this evening so just
shake your head at me and i will
immediately stop asking that question so
we haven't heard anything about the
internal layout of the building and i
wondered for example that the stairs
travel at the middle of the house or the
outside of the house i'm just trying to
work out the impact of
of that number of people living next
door
thank you
so the stairs are where they would have
originally been um which is um on the
outs so it would have been on the
outside wall so it it'll be in the
center of the house um i can't my cursor
doesn't
it's fine so i understand it so there
are rooms that do a join next door yes
yes there are bedrooms
and i have no idea whether this is ever
a condition of building hmos and
obviously this house wasn't developed
with that ultimate intention but are
there ever any possibility of sound
proofing those
walls at neighbor
next door
you can just shake your head we can
we do sometimes condition in
applications that walls need to be
soundproof when for example people are
proposing a nursery where it's a it's
likely to be a different noise um
compared to a property however that
condition hasn't come through from our
hmo officers
um and also i suppose if its bedrooms
are joining you wouldn't necessarily
expect that to be it's householder noise
yeah and so we'd have to wonder if it's
reasonable and to to kind of
to have sound proofing
i suppose
yes and also yeah that's a good point if
you sound proof then it would then
probably reduce the space and these will
meet our minimum space standards so we
we wouldn't want to see a reduction in
the quality of the rooms no um
most of my issues around it do rest with
it being semi-detached i do feel that
the neighbors are under an awful lot
of stress and novelty you know and their
anticipation of how it might be however
it does ultimately end up being i do
have every sympathy with um
again i think this probably isn't our
remit but maybe somebody could put
so it suggested that um
the landlord would manage any complaints
which is an unusual relationship to have
with your neighbours usually if you have
a relationship with your neighbors you
are able to directly converse with them
but obviously there will be
perhaps regular changes of tenancy if
it's considered for short-term less so
it will be unlikely that neighbours are
able to develop those usual
relationships where they can speak to
each other about difficulties that might
be causing each other and it's been
suggested that the landlord will manage
those i just wondered
in terms of letting how would he manage
that so would it be a matter of
responding and
make giving um the short-term tenants
advice
is he does he have any facility to move
the money for our continued difficulty
and also would we want to set up a
accommodation where tendency was that in
substa you know the tendency was so
insubstantially protected that they were
in a position to be regularly moved on
so i'm a little bit concerned about how
it's going to work in the future
and seeing as these are part of the
conditions as they understand them i
just like to know a little bit more
about it
so
we are proposing to condition the
management plan
this is being submitted by a property
company so
um i assume lettings would go the same
way
that hmos are usually left which is
through um
kind of an estate agent management
company and but we don't we're not
involved in that directly
in terms of if people are
um acting up
that is not something we could comment
on it kind of strays beyond planning i
mean there have there's a management
plan and but beyond that it would be
something between the
the management agency and and the
residents and and we're not here
to almost um
predict people's behavior
and we are we and i know utas and we
can't almost kind of police that
behavior um and and kind of preempt how
people will act just because they live
in a hmo so
it's what we can put in practical
measures
um rather than
behavioral measures yeah it's just
because the management plan is part of
the recommendation um and i'm not
familiar
familiarity with how management plans
for hmo's work all right well thank you
very much you
answered as much as you could thank
thank you councillor thomas
thank you chair um i'm against this on
a couple of reasons lots of lots of
meaning to the neighbours
it's a huge difference between having
um
a house with six occupants in
to having potentially four bedrooms on
the adjoining wall of a semi-truck house
with four different uh
people is it five sorry
uh with five different rooms having five
different sounds coming from it onto an
adjoining wall there's no way of getting
away from that i think that eight people
is overcrowding over a house of the size
and i also
would like to know how
if there are five double rooms how it's
managed that we are aware that
there is only one person in each double
room
um
car parking locally
none of none of the car if if for
example we had eight people in that
property and all of them had vehicles
none of the
vehicles that have no space on the
property can park on the corner that
would be illegal there's a mini
roundabout there and the
parking facility is along
both winchester and more more
importantly mossvale are very limited as
a short and busy road so i think lots of
amenities to neighbours
lots of immunity to
uh next door to enjoy a
residential life and in the way that we
would expect are the reasons i have
against against this
um
and i propose that we reject the
officer's recommendation to grant
my future okay thank you councillor um
councillor bunting please
thank you chairman again i'm
far from happy with this application
i agree with many of the points have
been made particularly surrounding the
effect on the neighbors in terms of the
noise as it's already been pointed out
you know sort of eight individual
bedrooms five of which are joining to
the
uh to the next ornate next door
neighbors is very different to a house a
single family even a large single family
in a house because you know a single
family will obviously maybe spend time
more in a living room where you're gonna
have people in the bedrooms
each with their own television and
they're each making their own noise each
listening to meet different sets of
music
what have you uh so the level of
disturbance to next door would be
significant we've already touched on the
suggestion of whether soundproofing
would be appropriate but that would then
reduce the standard of reliving
accommodation and therefore the officers
don't uh wish to have that this council
accordingly also points out
and i must admit i agree with him the
idea that the signs of kitchen
that is present within this property is
going to be suitable for eight separate
sets of adults all trying to cook that
in at the same time because people will
generally want to eat you at the same
time so the standard of the
accommodation that we're proposing is
very low uh and the rooms are just about
within but obviously not large enough to
associ uh you know accommodating sound
proofing so they're just within it
so again i'm not happy on that and also
in terms of parking i think that as
council thomas has already pointed out
and others have mentioned uh there are
significant issues in relation to that
uh both in terms of the number of cars
that may well be present on this site
you could easily imagine eight cars the
fact that you've got the miniband about
me and people can't park immediately
outside it's already an area which
suffers from congestion in terms of cars
as it is it will simply exacerbate and
make that worse so this is
this is uh not suitable for this
location uh counselor knowledge points
out this year simply for people who wish
to use hmos and i share that sympathy
they are
a facility that many people may wish to
make use of but this is the wrong
location for such a facility uh i think
council thomas proposed refusal i don't
think i've heard any of it so i'm more
than happy to second his proposal uh and
i will be uh voting against officer
recommendation myself for those three
reasons i've just outlined thank you
chairman
thank you um councillor wetton please
thank you um
like counselor dagnol i think this is
just too much
on the site of a semi-detached
house
it's um it's in congress on on that
residential street
and i think it will just introduce
pressures
um that will just cause
difficulties
um
i have to say my naivety it's a long
time since i heard the expression house
in multiple occupation i almost thought
it had gone out of the language and it
came as a bit of a shock to me to see
uh a proposal for such a large
hmo
um
being carved out of a semi-detached
house
um when i look at the plans
i
uh there's so many things that just jar
with me for thinking about eight
different individuals living in one
house so you've got
uh three toilets for individuals just
doesn't sound
enough to me uh if we look at the
kitchen plan if that is the actual
kitchen plan it seems to have one sink
that just doesn't seem right to me
looking at the communal areas
that on there they look inadequate for
the numbers of people
if um
with eight into if there were eight
individuals
uh living there
um
the lounge space just doesn't work the
dining space just doesn't work it's just
not adequate
and the
the dynamics
of a large family home are i
believe are very very different to a
house in in multiple occupation
and
this
the idea of putting an hmo uh on this
residential street just just jars
i i get the feeling that this
application ticks many boxes
um
but for me it is just not acceptable
i think we've heard from other members
of the committee
about these sorts of um reasons why it's
not right and i've agreed i've agreed
with all of them and i've added mine so
i won't be able to support this thank
you
thank you councillor maitland
um everything's been covered really um
from what i wanted to say but
one of the things i was thinking about
is that the family who've moved next
door i think they bought the property in
august the year before
um is that right has everyone anyone
seen that um
i think they've gone into that as their
forever home and had to have this um and
that potential all that noise coming
through i just couldn't agree with this
i have every sympathy mr shah with his
what what he wants to do but um and can
i also say i actually think the building
looks quite really quite nice i haven't
got a problem with the look but um i
don't think it's going to be for me
you thank you council um councillor
morgan please
thank you chair um
i i can probably agree with a lot of the
comments that have been made um
and it is although i don't want to go
over the issue um the the building um
itself having been significantly
increased in the permitted developments
it is quite staggering that is
it's allowed um
i mean i agree with a lot of the
comments but i was i was listening
particularly to council i canola about
i i looked at the hmo standards and the
planning rules before this meeting i had
a re-look at them tonight like and a lot
of the things that i don't like about
this do meet the standards the bathroom
the number of bathrooms the size of the
rooms
even the parking is within although it's
staggering to think but is within the
rules um and our minimum standards the
living area um
and and so i do think
we're on difficult ground arguing on
those points despite the fact of what
our own natural feelings would be
the one that
and
again i'm not 100 sure but i is
listening to councillor thomas and
councillor bunting on on the immunity
for the neighbours um i make a
statement i would imagine this type of
house semi is probably about as typical
as for trafford as
exists and i'm sure many of us on this
committee live in very similar houses
and i certainly do and the fact that you
could
live next to a semi-detached house which
becomes a six bedroom house is quite
staggering but to them become eight
bedrooms um
it would be you know a lot of us you
know you put yourself into the into a
position and
um and the impact i i i agree with that
counts i know that eight
eight people in the family could live in
this house that is a completely
reasonable expectation but families work
differently to eight separate families
um or eight separate individuals shall
we say um and they will be a bigger
impact than eight eight individual
adults or eight people and including
children living there so
um i think probably i will be voting
against this on the on the grounds of
immunity but it is um i do think some of
the some of the grounds have which we've
been raised um are covered with minimum
standards thank you
thank you thank you very much um
councillor welton
uh yes i think like a lot of people i
was instinctively um
opposed to this but was struggling to
find the reasons for it but uh
having
realized that five of the rooms do
are
along the party wall with the neighbors
you just can't see this this being
right or fair
you know for for the neighbors to have
to put up with the potential noise and
disturbance from those five five
different different rooms i also taking
on um council accordingly's point about
um
uh about the the air quality um there is
also another another potential source of
air um
quality harm and that's the sheer amount
of cooking that could well be going on
in the kitchen dining room if you've got
eight different people cooking in that
one that one kitchen then that can
actually seriously harm the air quality
in the rest of the house
um and that could you know be a
significant source of harm to all the
residents
um i think if this was a detached
property then i think you know it meets
the guidance the room sizes look okay i
mean
um
but uh i think
given its semi-detached nature i don't
think in good conscious i could
i i could vote in favor of this
um thank you very much
[Music]
okay um i think every member of the
committee has now spoken to this item it
has been proposed i believe by
councillor
can we just clarify the reason i can
tell you what i'm
understanding yeah so it's been proposed
in second digital refusal can you just
explain see if members are happy with
the reasons that you've noted if that's
okay thank you
i would um echo councillor morgan's
comments about um concern over refusing
it on um the standard of the
accommodation in terms of the the the
room sizes given they do make policy but
from the comments received i understand
you're saying due to the scale of the
development and nature of the scale of
the number of rooms um and nature of the
property that it would have an
acceptable impact on amenity
to clarify
is on the loss of amenities and
neighbors must i agree that she meets
and takes some of the boxes has been
discussed we also take into account the
effect it has on the local
uh environment and the immunities of
neighbors and it's
for me particularly five bedrooms
against the party wall will cause
unnecessary lots of immunity to live a
normal family life for the neighbours
that's that's why i was saying that due
to the scale of the number of bedrooms
that it would have an acceptable impact
on amenity of neighbours
in addition chairman uh if i may the
only way in which such loss of immunity
could be mitigated would be some
fairly serious
noise mitigation measures which as your
officers have already pointed out would
unduly affect the size of the
rooms for those five becoming you know
those five bedrooms so unless you're
gonna start putting very serious sound
insulation in which as your officers
have already pointed out would be uh
detrimental to the room size basically
you can't condition your way out of this
one either
so therefore refusal is the only option
on those grounds because you just just
can't get around it with conditions
thank you chairman
i don't we haven't said that it would
and julie i think we said we just don't
know
i think also there's concerns
um with the highways and where it's
actually located
um on the road structure around that
it is quite difficult to potentially
have eight vehicles
parked in
in in their car parking space that they
okay mr emerson perhaps if you could
comment
yeah thank you um yeah i've listened to
the the conversation just
but in terms of highways as it's being
um suggested
it does actually meet the max it's the
maximum standard and not minimum which
is quite surprising quite often we don't
get that
in terms of the access 2x they currently
have two access points
on both roads both
very dangerous
but but the the thing which where i'm
coming from is we have to judge what's
already there
whether we like it to a long beat
it currently and they're proposing three
four parking spaces within the site
which fully meets the maximum standards
for parking
which would be very difficult to argue
against yes each of the occupiers may
very well have a car
but the requirements are for parking
spaces so that'd be really difficult to
argue that at an appeal and that would
potentially weaken your case i would
suggest but that's for members to
consider
and and also the two access points are
already there
so they're not introducing anything new
on the highway so even whether it's a
six bedroom dwelling or whether it's an
eight bedroom hmo
that the two
those those spaces those those access
points are already there it would be
very difficult again at an appeal to
argue that that particular point so
what's being suggested
is i would suggest is probably the best
way forward for members to support as
opposed to adding
the highway issues into the refusal
which may jeopardize
the ultimate outcome
are you happy
to take that position well i don't agree
with you but
that's my view i think i think i have a
different view
never seen the two accesses working
i've only seen the one and that's from
the front not the side yeah but but they
are actually there
well they might have an access have they
got a drop pavement there yes
i didn't see the top
yeah um
remember i think members have got
one reasonably strong reason for refusal
and that's the fact that the properties
have been detached um
i think
that there is um a reasonable prospect
of that being um upheld at appeal the
other two the the nature of the
accommodation the parking i think um are
far weaker and uh i agree with mr
robertson could could even undermine the
case so my recommendation would be go go
with the one strong reason for refusal
um and and and see what see where that
gets you
thank you councillor walton and thomas
he did both indicate you wanted to just
i was going to say that so basically
just uh just to reiterate my point and
if you want to stay the parking lot it
wasn't about the number of parking
spaces it's about where the people had
to safely park there's lots of immunity
to other neighbors in the area
mosswale road cannot carry on street
parking realistically uh that's why i
was thinking but if we're happy to go
with the one i'm more than happy to keep
it lost when we need
okay
can i just
come in i'm i'm not quite sure why
it would reduce our
ability to win the case by having two
um you know
submissions
of
disagreement
i i i don't understand
why
it it it's because a case is a case is
looked as as a whole and
if in cases where
there are lots of minor points which
don't really carry
it undermines the credibility of the
whole case because the inspector just
goes well that's that's not
you know that that goes nowhere that
goes nowhere that that goes nowhere and
gets to the last thing well you know
whereas if you see one and goes yes i
can agree with that then you know it's
not necessarily
you know i'm not saying that absolutely
will happen um you know if you speak to
to any planning barrister they always
say stick with your big picture stick
with your strong points don't try and
throw things in that that you think
might stick but but might not because
you won't it doesn't help you
i'm quite happy with
the converse of that
uh can you assure us that that is not
the case that by putting just one item
forward
uh that doesn't get looked at as well
i've only put one small item port here
okay so you can
assure us that you're advising the best
way of getting
this
past any appeal process
yes one item where there is a clear
matter of planning judgment
that has been applied and that members
can reasonably come to a different view
to offices on on this and and and here
that's in that's the case you know this
this is this is not one where i'm saying
don't go go there this is one where i'm
saying yes you could entirely reasonably
come to a different view to us
because it's not a particular standard
where you've got a particular standard
and it meets it
at that point
if you're putting reasons for for
refusal on you do start to undermine
your case because it quite clearly
complies with with the standards that
that we've we've set out so
that's where i say you you shouldn't be
you shouldn't be going there because
that that simply won't go anywhere
just in terms of clarification in terms
of the parking if the parking was below
the standard
in terms of the maximum then i would
suggest that would probably carry some
weight
but because it meets spd3
and it meets the maximum
that's why i'm saying it would be
difficult in terms of
the problem whereas if it was below that
then i would say yeah with there's a
good chance to add that to any reason
for refusal
okay i i think it's probably worth
moving to a vote now he's spoken to this
item for really quite a long time it's
been proposed and seconded that
permission for this change of use
application be refused contrary to
officer recommendation if members
inclined to support that motion can
indicate now please
thank you and those not supporting that
motion can indicate please
okay thank you so that motion's carried
and permission for that application is
refused
um well now turn to application 105
double nine one sixteen aspen would
drive in sale which is on page 29 of the
committee report and before we hear from
speakers the application will be
introduced by mr day
uh thank you sir
okay this application relates to a
two-story semi-detached property located
on aspen wood drive in sale
um planning permission is sought for the
erection of a single-story front
extension
part single part two-story side
extension
and a single-story rear extension
the application has been called into
committee by councillor holden
on the grounds of over development
impact on the neighboring property
and a detrimental change to the street
scene
one addre one objection has been
received raising concerns that the
proposal would result
in a loss of light to the neighboring
property in particular to the front
garden and kitchen stroke living room
and stating that the plans should be
amended to only extend to the rear
[Music]
it's considered that the proposed
extension is acceptable in terms of
design and visual immunity
and would not have an unacceptable
impact on the residential community of
neighbouring dwellings
as such it's considered that the pose
development will be in accordance with
policy l7 of the core strategy
and guidance in the mppf
and the application is therefore
recommended for approval subject
conditions
thank you mister
um there's two speakers speaking against
this application um councillor holden
and lisa ditchima have you decided who'd
like to speak
sorry i've confused that so there's one
speaker speaking against this
application that'll be councillor holden
um if you can just come sit in front of
the microphone counselor you've got five
minutes to speak
before we start the clock okay ask a
question please
on the
database to which i had access
there was a letter
written by
the resident of 19
expressing her concerns
it was very heavily redacted
on the form that i saw
have the committee seen the unredacted
version of that letter
that can't speak for everyone i have not
seen i've adapted
so the
only document you've seen is the heavily
redacted version
okay
that slightly changes what uh what i
wanted to say
but um
slightly strange situation here as many
of you will be aware
i live
in the area that i represent
which means that i have a mild influence
of mild interest
in this situation as i am one of the
extended
family of residents of this area who all
walk their dogs and talk to each other
and one day i was approached
by louise the representative the
resident of number 19
who was frankly distraught
at the application that she had been
informed of through the standard system
so i said
to her
that i would bring it to you
so that you consider it
inside the
confines of this committee
if you'd seen the unredacted version of
the letter you would have seen that
the resident
of number 19
has a number of issues which are quite
clearly not planning issues that affect
her well-being and her health
very briefly
we have
some comments in the report
which i'd just like to
cast a small doubt on
and only a small one
first one
no undue overbearing or overshadowing
impact
on the neighboring property
now please be aware
as i'm sure you probably are if you've
visited the site
that
the neighboring property that is causing
the concern
is a single story flat
so although this is a relatively small
extension it actually
actually is the equivalent of something
much bigger if the property at number 19
was two stories
and
one has to agree it's
subjective
um
but do you have an opinion having seen
it
the hipped roof is considered
modest in scale
not if you only have a single storey
house
of property facing it
and certainly not if you're looking at
it every day
and certainly not
if you're watching this torrent of
brickwork approaching your property
during the construction process
positively claustrophobic
and the comment about the creation of
parking space
on street parking
that is factually wrong
there is no
on-street parking opportunity on
aspenwood as all the kerbs are the
frontage of other people's houses
there is a car park which is taken up by
the residents of the local block of
flats but there is no space
on that road
available for on-street parking and this
development
pushes the parking space available at
the front
of number 19
forward to an extent
where
more than one vehicle would be difficult
so we have a situation i'll finish with
a summary
the property
that's being developed the development
and normal circumstances will be almost
insignificant
but in the position that it is and with
the neighbors as they are
it is significant it's
unpleasant the properties stepped back
and you'll notice that from the floor
plan or the street plan
that's being included in the report
i believe that was deliberate to provide
space
what we're talking about here
is moving into that free air space with
a forward facing extension
whatever you decide
if you decide to grant
then the residents are faced in this
rather narrow rather tight cul-de-sac
with weeks or perhaps months of
disruption and noise and i know that
you're not allowed
to consider that
as members of this planning committee
please try and commit consider it as
human beings
and that is the end of my rather slender
case
and i'll just finish by saying
it's very often better to be kind than
to be right
thank you
thank you and speaking in favor of the
application is lisa ditra
hi
thanks um for joining us this evening if
you can just ensure the microphones on
you've got three minutes to speak if you
run over time i'll just politely ask you
to wrap up your contribution thank you
uh good evening thank you for em allow
me the opportunity to speak this evening
um
i've just explained the um i know it's
been explained here before but if i can
just say the majority of our plan is for
a ground floor extension i know it has
mentioned at the front extension but
that at the moment we don't have a porch
which some of the houses on that
on aspen would drive do have porches so
it would be the porch which is extended
across to make um the utility or
downstairs bathroom
a little bit longer because we don't
have much space because we have a double
drive at the side and and obviously we
have to come in almost a meter anyway so
it wouldn't leave much space it's just
to make it that little bit longer in
length and the plan for the double
extension is only at the front side of
the house which would allow for an
extended box room bedroom uh the
remainder of the side extension would
just be a single story which would be a
wrap around extension that would give us
an extended kitchen and dining room a
downstairs toilet as at the moment we
just have one bathroom upstairs and it
would also provide us with a utility
room um
our three children are now young adults
and still live at home and this would
give us more much needed space
we originally wanted to do a full double
extension so we could have an extra
bedroom upstairs however due to this
causing the neighbors either side to
have their view affected this was not
requested and the plan submitted was the
best alternative available without
causing an unnecessary impact on our
neighbours
it certainly isn't um
us trying to build our dream home as was
referred to in the objection it's a
standard extension to allow more much
needed space for myself my husband and
three young adults um with the current
climate obviously it's difficult for
young people to buy or rent their first
home so it's not a simple option for us
ourselves to buy another home that would
suit the size of our family without
possibly looking to leave the trafford
area which we would not ideally want to
do
the side kitchen window which was
referred to and does overlook our
driveway however it's a frosted glass
window and it's already partially
covered by the neighbor's high fence
panel which was fitted by the neighbor
herself it's not the only window into
that room as these flats have open plan
living room kitchen areas with a large
window at the front of the property
um
[Music]
the extension itself would only
literally uh come out about six inches
past the the site where the side window
is and obviously there's um
her her own dr um her own pathway and
our driveway space between that too
um
and the other window is a very small
bathroom window it's about only about 12
inches in length and again that's
fitting with frosty glass
we currently have two large sheds in the
driveway where the extension would be
and the extension would replace these
and also enhance the look at the front
of the property and therefore the
general neighborhood it will
additionally provide an extended family
residential property in the area
um i know parking has been addressed um
along with the uh for the object
objection but um the parking would not
be affected by the extension um the
front of the house porch only comes out
about one meter and uh it would still
allow us to put to park on the driveway
we would also be taking um would be flag
in the driveway to allow for
another car to be parked on the driveway
anyway
um
and in relation to um the redacted
report it was all in relation to um
to mental health and we understand that
louise has got some of these issues etc
but um
we've done everything that we can in
order to have as a reasonable size house
that wouldn't affect um our neighbours
and
we're friendly with majority of the
neighbours in the neighborhood and none
of them have got any objections i know
we're not here to discuss that because
they haven't objected but um they're
quite happy with what what we've got
planned
okay thank you thank you for
speaking to us tonight um i don't count
the bunting indicating you'd like to
open the discussion
thank you chairman yes it's scenario i
know well i council holden uh i share
this award with him uh
and council holder makes some very good
points i agree with some of this case uh
specifically in relation to the second
story of the side extension whilst it's
then stated in report the objectives
would be happy if it was just rear only
i think that is perhaps some duly
restrictive
uh if it was
the the porch i could is not ideal as
council holden has pointed out the
parking is non-existent in this area
other than the official car park you
cannot park
anywhere else it's a very tight uh
estate in terms of parking when i turned
that really there wasn't a single
parking space
available and the only way i could park
to go and visit the site was to block
the resident in but given the fact that
i was going in to go and see the
resident i didn't think this would be
too much of a problem
if it was a case of well single story
rear side and front
then i'd probably wear it i think that
would be okay that would not have too
much of it but it's a c this is
specifically that second storage i think
will have
a significant impact upon the the object
uh simply by virtue being a two-story if
it was a single sorry side then i think
that would be acceptable and that would
not have too much of an impact and would
still be uh give it resident the
majority of that which you wishes so
whilst i i'm
how i know council holding the subject
to the front uh extension i think that
is an issue it's not ideal but it's
doable it's wearable uh whereas the
double sorry to the side i think will
have an
excessive impact upon the nave i think
it will cause undue loss of immunity
through excessive overshadowing i think
that yes there is overshadowing at the
moment but i think this will make it
significantly worse
and so for that one reason
uh on the objections that i'm i'm happy
to propose
that we uh refuse in convention of the
officer recommendation and i'll wait to
see what my colleagues have to say thank
you gentlemen
thank you councillor thomas
thank you chair i'm afraid in this case
i disagree completely with what
councilman has just said
i think it's quite sympathetic to the
neighbours in
so far as where the side extension goes
up to two floors i would not have been
particularly adverse to it being the
full length of the building it just sets
back slightly the afternoon from
mid morning onwards the sunlight would
be going forward so therefore
the
neighbors at um
17 and 19 would be even less affected
uh
i think it's quite considerate to
the area i don't know as well as uh
councilman council holding but i'm i'm
happy to propose that we accept the
officer recommendation
thank you councillor morgan
thanks for um i'm going to disagree with
council thomas and the council one thing
i i i although for different reasons um
to agree with council blunting i have
less problem with the rear extension
um but i i really do think the side
extension um i've
not
sorry i thought it was the side
extension you were fine with
no just to clarify before cancer work
continues i'm fine with the rear
extension it was the side extension the
double story aspect if the side
accenture was a single story that i
would not have a concern if it it's a
fact that it's the double
second story on the side to which i
object not the rear to which i update
just just to clarify thank you
thank you yeah
follow the discounts to hunting um
even a single story i i would have
concern over um
the spaciousness of it um and i i do
know this not as well as council hunting
council holding clearly but relatively
well
um
and i do think the impact of that
particularly that side extension um
we'll have on
um
a flat downstairs um so i'm more than
happy to support council bluntings um
if you propose council hunting but i'm
happy second if you have um um proposal
to refuse um um
uh contrary to officer recommendations
i
can't see anybody else that come from
winston
uh thank you chair i'm gonna disagree
with the the previous speaker i
think this is sympathetic to the area
in which it is planned i understand the
concerns of the residents i really do
but they're all very
very well dealt with in the report so
i'm happy to second the proposal that we
uh approve in live loft's recommendation
thank you cheer
any other members who want to contribute
counselor
um
i just wondered um the resident made
reference to the fact that she should be
paving over the rest of the front garden
i wonder if there's any opportunity to
recommend the permeable materials we
used
oh is that not within our arena again
yeah i mean
it would be possible to condition that
we uh condition a further parking space
and with permeable permeable materials
yeah if that's
i i think that would improve it and i
know it makes no difference to extension
or to the facilities next door but i
haven't looked at it and being here
tonight and given the opportunity to
comment on it i i think that would be an
improvement on the plan and which i have
today i'm reasonably favorable towards
anyway but
is that the end of your contribution
i'll finish speaking now
um counselor
i i would just say that the way i um
assess this is that the applicant has
made
um a reasonable um
request to extend their home they've
clearly not
pushed it as far as they could have done
um
and and
you know i think they could have asked
for more and still got a recommendation
of approval they haven't done they've
tried to be
sympathetic to the the neighbors
um
i think it
it's it's
it sits well enough it's just one of
those situations where the neighbor
doesn't like what's
um
you know possibly coming
um
i think in in the end it'll
it'll sit quite comfortably next to the
neighboring property
[Music]
and
the only bit i can see was at all
controversial was the second the second
story part and i just think that um i
can and you know the the idea that you
could just have the the ground floor
done
and but i can see why why the applicant
wants um you know a box room up there
and i really think that like like
council western said there could have
gone further and and haven't really and
i think have actually con they've
considered their neighbor and i'm a fan
of that so
um
i like i like the you know considering
your neighbor and trying to find
something that that's um
you know that's better
better for everybody suits everybody so
i'm in support of the applications and
if it and was it proposed you propose it
i'll suck i'll happy second if it's not
the second did we do second okay yep i'm
in favor though thank you
sorry i don't know for that confusion um
just on
the proposal around um
permeable materials being used
would you be comfortable with that
yeah okay
a member's happy for that to be a
condition
okay i'm councillor welton
is that not a rule anyway i believe
having spent a little bit of time
looking at the council's policy on
driveways i think it's something that
good upstanding citizens are supposed to
do anyway
okay
so it's been proposed and seconded that
permission for this um application be
refused contrary to officer
recommendation we'll take that vote
first
members who wish to refuse permission
for the application can indicate now
please
okay and those not supporting that
and indicate please
all right okay so
that motion is not carried we'll now
take the motion
that was proposed and seconded the
permission be granted in line with
officer recommendation
with the condition included around
permeable materials
is that okay members supporting that
motion can indicate okay make that
turn in those not supporting
okay
so that motion's carried and permission
for that application is approved thank
you
discussion we'll now turn to application
105 195
london north of
junction of st margaret's road and gobi
road in altrincham which can be found on
page one of the committee report
before we
hear from speakers the application is
going to be introduced very much today
thank you chair um
this application relates to a plot at
the corner of grobe road
and saint margaret's road in bowdoin
the site is located within the
devilsville conservation area
with hill carr the adjacent property to
the rear north
noted as a positive contributor
there have been two previous permissions
for the erection we're drawing at the
application site with the most recent
9765419
granted in march 2020
however the development has not been
built out wholly in accordance with the
approved plans
the current application is therefore
part retrospective and seeks approval
for the works that have taken place
the proposal is reported to the planning
and development management committee as
the application has received 11 letters
of objection
contrary to the officer recommendation
of approval
the part completed development of a flat
roofed single story dwelling
with associated hard and soft
landscaping and a new vehicle access
onto grobe road to the south
the amendments to the previously
approved scheme include the
repositioning of the vehicle access
slightly further approximately two
meters to the southwest along grady road
and alterations to hard and soft
landscaping works
the previously approved elevation
drawings also incorrectly overstated the
height
of the ground level of the adjacent plot
to the rear at hill carr
meaning that the as-built scheme now
appears to be more prominent
compared to what was previously shown on
the approved elevations
although it has been implemented in
accordance with the levels shown on the
layout plans
the current application includes amended
elevation drawings showing the correct
ground levels
as originally submitted the current
application included artificial grass in
place of the previously approved green
roof
the addition of roof lights
and the installation of a walkway
between the dwelling and the rear
boundary with hill car
following discussions um with the
applicant the plans have now been
amended
to show the infilling of the walkway
the removal of the roof lights and the
reinstatement of the green roof
and screening vegetation to the side
southwest boundary
to ensure that the scheme would have a
similar design to the previously
approved scheme
uh i'll just quickly run through the
plans
on the screen
you can see in the the
top uh
section aaa on that plan that's the
site viewed from the east
um looking towards the boundary with
coppice lodge
and you can see the proposed bleach
trees
along the boundary there and the
dwelling
the section through the dwelling
there
the elevation below that shows this site
as you look
from the south
looking
to the front of the dwelling
and to
you can see the property at hill carr
behind that
uh some some more sections
viewed from the east
from various points in the site
uh that shows the layout of the
the ground floor plan
of the drawing
site plan
um so you can see the vehicle access
there from grobe road
um with the access the driveway curving
around
to parking spaces um the towards the
eastern end of the site and a pathway
through
to
the drawing
and a proposed landscaping plan
um showing
the bleach trees on the
western boundary and more tree planting
along
the northern boundary
uh that's that's the access gates which
are unchanged from the previous
permission
um these drawings
just simply um
illustrate the changes that are
well
that have been
introduced to this application in terms
of the ground level
um previously having been
shown
slightly below the adjacent site
um
and the the bottom
section shows
the proposal to
amend the ground levels
adjacent to the hillcar site
to fill in the walkway um
and
make it appear more
similar to
what well to a dwelling that
that merges into the existing ground
level there
uh some photographs that shows the um
the site from the south from the access
looking north with hill car behind it
and looking east across the site
the rear boundary at the moment which is
obviously going to be filled in
and another part of the rear boundary
where the
new 1.8 meter fencing
has been erected
um as was the case with the previous
application the proposal is considered
to cause less than substantial harm
to heritage assets with the public
benefits arising for the proposals not
considered to outweigh that harm
nevertheless there is a fallback
position
in this case the previously approved
scheme
9765 full 19
which could still be implemented and
it's considered that following the
amendments that have been negotiated
and subject to appropriate conditions
the current proposal would not have a
significantly more detrimental impact on
the character and appearance of the
conservation area
than that previously approved scheme
this fallback position is an important
material consideration
and is considered to outweigh the
identified conflict with the mppf and
the development plan
and the harm to heritage assets the
application is therefore recommended for
approval subject conditions
thank you mr day um there's one speaker
speaking in favor of this application
valve taylor hi mr taylor thanks for
joining us if um you can just make sure
the microphone's on you've got three
minutes to speak if you run over time
i'll just ask you to wrap up your
contribution thank you
good evening committee my name is ralph
taylor of public associates we're the
planning consultants for this
application
the application involves a small number
of minor amendments to an existing
planning permission the amendments are
associated with regularizing the
development to facilitate its completion
we've worked positively with officers
during the processing of the application
and you will note from the officer's
report that a number of positive changes
have been made
these changes have included the
provision of a sedum roof to promote
biodiversity and minimize visual impact
the removal of roof lights
the removal of a walkway at the warrior
of the building and provision of
additional and improved landscaping
across the site
in determining this application it's
important to be mindful of this extant
planning permission which is the
material consideration of substantial
weight
i'd like to say a few words on the
amendments that are proposed to the
previously limited scheme these include
one replacing timber boundary fencing on
a light flight basis
two regularizing the height of the
building
the approved height of the building was
clearly identified as 3.2 metres on
approved plans based on ground levels
roof height and finish floor levels
survey measurements have confirmed that
building is constructed to this height
and is no taller there is an unfortunate
irregularity with the suggested heights
on some other properties this was due to
use of earlier survey drawings which
appear to be inaccurate this amendment
is therefore to ensure consistency and
accuracy although to be clear the height
of the approved building has not changed
three minor adjustments in the position
of the site entrance by only 1.5 meters
to reduce impact on existing boundary
planting
the movement of the entrance further
away from the junction with st
margaret's road has a positive safety
impact which has been confirmed by the
local highways authority
four there are landscaping alterations
which have allowed for additional soft
landscaping including tree planting to
provide screening tree and plant species
have been sensitively selected by the
landscape architects and are supported
by the council's agricultural officer
more sustainable materials are proposed
including a uni-locked timber retaining
wall system which will be softened by
trailing plants and flowers
during the construction process new
issues inevitably come to light and
proposals sometimes need to change and
be adapted with amendments and a
legitimate part of the finance system
the current application will regularize
these matters whilst also delivering
enhancements and benefits
when considering the changes to the
scheme it is important to recognize the
screen character of the site which is
enclosed with boundary walls and mature
vegetation which will be further
supplemented with new planting
realistically there will only be a
glimpse view into the site from the
gated access
from this viewpoint elements within the
application will not be perceptible and
the dwelling will retain its subservient
character
on this basis there will not be any
material impact on the character
appearance of the conservation area
against the backdrop of the fallback
position we consider that there are no
legitimate reasons for withholding
planning permission with the proposals
complying with national and local
planning policy
on this basis we respectfully request
that members support their officers
recommendation and grant buying
permission thank you
thank you thanks for that um counselor
what whetton you've indicated like to
open the discussion
thank you um well the site is in is in
my ward and i think um casting my mind
back
of some time i recall some controversies
around the previous applications that
are mentioned here
and perhaps this is just one of those
locations that
tends to
attract a lot of attention
um
i do have a lot of sympathy with the
objections raised by the representers
they haven't contacted me directly but i
but i think they've put
valid representations forward for
valid as near neighbors
um
i think that it's likely that though
those objectives will will not have
will not be totally fully okay with the
uh the element of the accident
planning permission and what that poses
overall
and i think that's the
the key of the uh issue for me in
similar to one of the early applications
that we dealt with
um
so
whilst i'm not happy uh to vote to
approve the application
um i think it is the lesser of two
lesser of two evils
so i'll vote in support of our officers
conclusions particularly those
conclusions and support of the
recommendation from our offices
thank you um are there any other members
who'd like to speak in the discussion
counselor walton
[Music]
thank you very much um
i think uh
the
objections to this um proposal have done
a good job because i think they've
got some
some excellent changes made to the plans
that have brought back some of the uh
some of the important individual
elements
of the scheme um whilst it doesn't go
the whole way and it would have been
good to have seen you know
the projects
um
built as
according to the original plans
um i i can't see that there's there's
enough um you know remaining after the
changes have been made to
um to
object to this further i mean it is a
very
exciting innovative development and uh
and and i'm sure residents will be very
glad to see it finished as well because
the the you know the building traffic
that's been caused by it is uh has been
substantial over time um so
sorry did you propose did you just
propose this i didn't actually normally
but i'm happy to do so
okay in which case i'll second it
thank you
thank you any of the members
wishing to
contribute now i mean i i think we had a
really detailed and considered report in
front of us this evening um
i have to say i agree with the planning
and balance conclusion no there was a
slight objection from the heritage
officer but it's nice to see that that
was um resolved uh with the applicant
and heritage officers now happy with the
application
um it has been proposed and seconded
that
the permission be granted in line with
officer recommendation members happy to
support that motion can indicate now
okay make that decision unanimous that
permission is granted
well now turn to application
five six 106.56
halal meat and vegetable shop in
altrincham which can be found on page 52
of the committee report
this application is going to be
introduced by ms milner
thank you chair the next application
relates to 208 and 210 moss lane and
hail the site is located on the west
side of moss lane on the corner with
clarence road and the end unit 210 is
currently occupied by grocery store
money halal meat and vegetable shop
while number 208 is currently vacant
there's a residential flat above
and 206 which he joins is a
physiotherapy practice um a ground floor
and a residential flat above
and the application is reported to
committee as um an officer has an
interest in the site and the application
proposes the erection of a single-story
side extension and external alterations
including a new shop front and the they
are proposing to amalgamate 208 and 210
and to create one single shop um the
side extension would have a hipped roof
let's move on to see the proposal um
with the door and window opening
alterations to the shop front will
create new double doors window openings
and an altered side door with canopy
and just to know following the
submission of the committee report
amended plans were received to increase
the width of the side door which you can
see
um top right hand corner um on the
chamfered corner there to one meter and
that has level access so that's to
provide an accessible entrance into the
unit
and
[Music]
it is noted that recently a metal canopy
structure has been erected to the front
with supporting poles that is not part
of this application and that will be
looked into separately
the key considerations relate to the
proposed change on the visual and
residential amenity parking bin storage
and highway safety and objections have
been received from three neighbors on
these grounds and also raising concerns
over structural issues which does not
form part of the material planning
considerations
um
the proposed external and the proposed
extension and external
alterations are considered to be
visually appropriate and of an
appropriate scale and design for the
area
and they're not considered to have an
undue impact on residential amenity
furthermore the amalgamation of the
units is not considered
um to increase parking demand um to
warrant refusal of the application
therefore subject to the conditions
outlined in the officer report we do
recommend approval thank you
thank you um there's no speakers
speaking to this item so any council
wishing to
open the discussion counselor thomas
thanks chad
once again it came to light while
reading through this
and was recognized
the widening of the door for
accessibility
as pointed out in the report has there
been a disabled impact assessment done
on this
property on the inside on the outside of
have we have we looked into
what
impact this will have on
disabled people around the area
no we've not done a specific impact
because this isn't a change of use this
is an existing unit and
it does already operate in parts it's an
amalgamation and there is level access
and proposed and so the level of
assessment is what we'd expect on a shop
unit we are we don't um it's not a
residential property it's a shop unit so
what we'd be looking at is primarily
just the level access
um of an appropriate width which it has
beyond that we haven't done any further
investigations because it's not
considered and
it would be appropriate given it isn't a
change of use
but double in sizes store accessibility
isn't just about going through the front
door is it
that is the original front door to the
to the property so there is still it is
still the main what could be considered
one of the main entrances into the
property
but i accept your point um but we have
this is we have sought to to increase or
improve the access
and again uh
it just seems to be that this keeps
coming up when we get plan applications
in
where
impact assessments on disabled access
whether it be
proposals like this
or
others seem to be on
the in the back of the mind this should
be at the forefront where we're afford
moving council
and we are looking to make
as much as we can
equal
with accessibility for all and i i just
i use it just that
i emailed rebecca earlier in the week
and
she replied saying that she was
obviously
uh declaring interest and removing
herself
but i heard nothing back from that
at all i'm it's just a it's a big
concern we're supposed to be leveling
leveling without wishing to use a
uh
a phrase leveling up leveling up
leveling up includes four i any um
equality for all
and it just seems i'm just concerned we
understand your perspective
i appreciate what you're saying we are
still limited by planning legislation so
i think we've raised it previously that
accessibility is covered in part
m of the building regulations so
much of
what you're referring to is covered
separately but i do know your point and
i think when we are we are looking at
policy and we are reviewing our local
plan at the moment and we are
in the process of producing a design
guide so improvements to accessible
access for all um is a consideration
thank you
thank you and i said i am particularly
in favor of
thank you
uh councilman morgan
thank you chair um and i think
councillor thomas has made some very
good points that i'm not going to try
and i'll add to them um
on those
um
i mean i i was going to raise very
different points um
i mean it's not particularly the most
pretty of it at extensions um and
although not in my ward it is actually
one of the main routes for mulching them
into my award um and i do think i look
down the representations and i think
quite a few of the points particularly
about parking are very fair um this is a
quite
a dangerous junction um but in fairness
this is not the only reason that the
parking is difficult um um where it is
located amongst quite a few different um
um
[Music]
businesses and and another um areas
which have significant amounts of um
um parking requirements um
i can't see a reason particularly to
oppose it um i mean it is really
frustrating that they've not exactly
helped
you know neighborhoodness um by putting
a metal um
um um extension um without any
applications on it um but again that's
not planning require that's planning
consideration so
um
i'm not going to propose that we support
this at this stage because i would be
interested to see all the council's
opinions but i can't see a reason at
this stage to oppose it thank you
thank you councillor winston
uh thank you chair i just want to return
to the point on um equalities that
counter thomas started to speak about
and just stress again as we've
acknowledged previous in this committee
um the equality laws apply to planning
decisions as much as they apply to
anything else and the public sector
equality duty actually places a duty on
us as a
public body to remove um
areas of discrimination and to
encourage the um the fair treatment of
everybody the protected characteristic
so it's perfectly acceptable to do any
quality impact assessments on everything
that we do
um
on this particular one uh i was quite
pleased to see that the plans were
amended to uh to widen the access and to
level the access
uh i think i'll probably vote in favor
of this thank you chair
thank you councillor wetton please
thank you um
this is an irrepressible business i
think
they do provide a good local service
but historically they do
play a bit fast and loose with planning
regulations
maybe
maybe um approval of this item will will
regulate them uh a bit more than they
have been in the past
um
time will tell so i will be supportive
of it um
but i do expect that uh in the fullness
of time there will still be a load of
external displays of uh
goods and uh
items that they want to
to extend their um in effect their sales
space
but as i say i will be supportive of it
thank you councilman um i don't think
it's been proposed or seconded the
permission be granted i'm happy to
propose the permission to be granted in
line with officer recommendation council
morgan i'll take you as a second in
there any other
members who wish to speak to this item
no okay well we'll move to the vote then
if members
who are happy to support the motion the
permission be granted this application
can indicate now please
okay make that decision unanimous and
that application is granted permission
we'll now turn to application 106 971
for farmed and drive in temporally which
can be found on page 72 of the committee
report
um this application will be introduced
by ms milner
thank you chair this application
releases a two-story semi-detached
property in timperley and the
application proposes um the erection of
a single story rear extension it's
reported to planning committee because
the applicant's father is a councillor
and no objections have been received as
detailed with in a committee report and
officers considered to be of an
appropriate design scale and therefore
do you recommend approval thank you
thank you council bunting
thank you chairman whilst i'm
severely tempted to entertain myself by
bringing forward the stream of
ridiculous conditions
and have a laugh at council reverend's
expense i will resist the temptation so
to do
and simply uh propose we recommend uh
what we follow the off circle into this
recommendation of grant as there is no
real reason not to thank you chairman
thank you councillor thomas
thank you chair unfortunately councilman
stole my thunder and i'm
and i'm happy to second the motion
the only members who want to speak to
the
item
no okay well we'll take that to the vote
then um
motion proposed the
application be granted in line granted
permission in line with office of
recommendation if members supporting
that motion can indicate now please
okay make that decision you know
well now turn to application
107.062
217 wood woodhouse lane east in
timberley which can be found on page 79
of the committee report
um
before we hear from speakers the
application is going to be introduced by
ms milner
thank you this application relates to
land to the side of 217 woodhouse
lainey's on the corner with fairborn
drive in timperley the site is at the
end of a row of terrorist properties
which serve commercial uses at ground
floor
and residential above
the application site is a grocery shop
at ground with residential flat above
last year an unauthorized flat roof upvc
clad side extension with roller shutter
was erected a retrospective planning
application was submitted however due to
the design and appearance of the
extension
and the application was recommended for
refusal and was refused at planning
committee in january of this year
the current proposal seeks to amend um
what has been constructed on site with
the current proposal um
to change the pitch of the roof um and
clad in in brick and remove the roller
shutters and um insert windows which um
are sympathetic to the existing property
um objections have been received
in relation to design parking access and
land ownership these have been duly
noted and considered within the body of
the committee report and the additional
information report
it is now considered at the proposed
side extension and following the the
amendments um would be of an approp
appropriate addition um to the existing
property
and we will be conditioning materials
and therefore subject to the conditions
outlined in the report we do not
consider it to have an undue impact on
highways and or design and residential
amenity thank you
thank you um
there is a speaker registered to speak
against the application yazmin sin who's
provided a statement which will be led
out by miss conley
thank you chair
i'm not happy with the extension that
has been built unlawfully at 217
woodhouse lane east i find the
additional structure unsightly and it
also looks unsafe this was built without
the permission of the landowners also
built before getting permission from the
council this trespassing on the land
brings detriment to the local area and
has also caused no unnecessary upset in
neighboring relations
being opposite the school in a nice
commercial area i feel the building is
unnecessary and doesn't fool the
character of the terrorist block and the
brit used the use of the upvc cladding
is not aesthetically pleasing and my
concern is also not fire safe especially
with the previous history of fire in
that property
along with the tenants trespassing on
land that doesn't belong to them and
also knowing
this when building the extension i find
disrespectful
due to this i find it was pre-meditated
to try and pass off the extension
without letting anyone know including
the council why was planning permission
not requested before building why
continue to build the extension we're
made aware that this is illegal
the document submitted states there are
two parking spaces within the property
this is incorrect the property does not
come with any parking spaces other than
road parking at the front
they have advised that they want to
bring more customers to the area however
this evening is no parking for this and
will cause customers to park on the road
and cause more traffic opposite the
school
the document also states notice was
given to the landowners
this is incorrect none of the three
owners of the land received any
notification
if this is accepted that legal matters
will commence and also the media will be
informed and this will bring negative
attention to the area
the entry will also be blocked by the
landowner so the property cannot be used
i feel that this matter will also be
escalated to the police due to
trespassing and potential confrontation
when the entrance to the extension is
blocked i strongly oppose this extension
thank you for considering my comments
thank you thank you um council i can
know that you're indicating
can i just clarify
is it from what i remember in the past
that ownership of the land isn't
something we get to consider so even if
it doesn't belong to them and it's been
built on that's none of our concern
and the proposals are saying that it
would be brick structure it wouldn't be
this
effort they've got there at the moment
thanks
thank you i mean i i can remember when
the previous application came before
committee and i think i said at that
time i'd be more than happy to support
an extension just
not with the materials that have been
used and
that is the case i'm happy with what's
been brought before us so i'm happy to
propose that we accept officer
recommendation and support and
permission being granted do any other
members the council of them think
yes thank you chairman it's
substantially better than the ridiculous
effort that was put there before or that
is still there
uh more than happy to second the
uh application as the reasons for
refusal have now effectively gone
although it is to a fair degree fantasy
planning application land that we're in
because the landowners made it quite
clear that they're not prepared to
give them a land so or sell them along
so it's
that but that's as kind of sucking
others already pointed out it's nothing
to do with us thank you jeremy thank you
are there any members who wish to
contribute to the discussion
no okay well it's been proposing a
second did the permission be granted in
line with officer recommendation
members who are supporting that motion
can indicate now please
okay make that decision unanimous that
permission is granted and we will now
turn to application 107 279 greenwood
community center in simply which can be
paid found on page 89 of the committee
report this application is going to be
introduced by muslim now
thank you um
this application has been reported to
planning committee because the building
is owned by the council and objections
have been received
broomwood community wellbeing center and
its associated facilities are located on
a large corner
bounded by mainwood road and greystoke
avenue in timperley
the application is to attend intended to
renew the previous permission um
93797 and which has lapsed um and
alterations to that permission as
approved um
under 101 160 and
the applicant um has had previously
discharged all their pre-commencement
conditions but when they went to start
on site earlier this year they became
aware that they were just out of time
and in regards to their three years
therefore they have resubmitted an
identical planning application
and clarified permission is sought for
the direction of a single-story
extension to the east and facing
elevation to form a sports hall with a
total floor space of 244 square meters
this proposed extension is in connection
with the existing timperley community
boxing club and which was established in
2012 and it will provide a boxing ring
floor space for training viewing areas
for the public fitness and weights areas
and toilets and changing facilities the
key considerations relate to the loss of
open space and the design the impact on
residential amenity and on parking and
highway safety
objections have been received in
relation to highways parking demand and
noise and antisocial behavior
and
the proposal has not changed since the
previous approvals and there were no
objections from statutory consultees i
would like to draw your attention to the
additional information
report there is some um
disagreement over the drainage plan at
the moment between united utilities and
our lead local flood authority so we've
amended the condition so that should
united utilities um confirm the
satisfaction of the drainage plan and
there'll be no further um delaying cost
to the applicant so it's just a slight
amendment to the wording
um
officers consider the proposal still
according to the development plan and is
an acceptable form of development and
therefore subject to conditions as
outlined in the committee report
and the additional automation report we
do recommend approval thank you
thank you councillor thomas indicated
you'd like to open this
thank you chair um
fully in favor of this i think there are
scant number of
facilities like this
across the country and
looking at the objections
traffic's existing
i
can't see any change in that that's
fantastic social behavior i think you'll
find that most places i have boxing
clubs find that the
behavior of youths in the area actually
improved through the discipline i'm
wholly behind this i think is an
excellent uh
development and i'm quite happy to
propose that we
accept officer recommendation
thank you councillor minis
i'm more than happy to second it the um
the boxing club has been really really
quite crucial to the roomwood estate and
to village ward and it's been really
really helpful for a lot of residents
and lots of people
have you know the facility is really
good for a lot of lots of the young
people there i'm
more than happy to support it thank you
very much thank you councillor
please
just briefly uh i support the views of
the last two speakers i think i think
this is an excellent facility
uh particularly for young people um but
what i wanted to ask um
is it
usual to
um to put in a report anonymous
representations it might be for some
reason but
i i just wonder why it is actually in
there
generally we don't count them but
because of the it was coming to
committee it was just noted because um
it kind of voiced previous refusals so
previous um
objections on the same site so i think
it's the same people we just didn't have
that confirmation so this time it's just
gone on
it's just seems strange to me that we we
do have it but anyway
i recognize the uh
what what you've actually said thank you
councillor canola
i just wanted to ask why were the
photographs redacted
which photographs are in if that was
sent in by
dineth is it then
the uh representative who put
representation and they weren't happy
photos that were anonymous were
they probably included um
personal information so it might have
had a bit of my car registration power
registrations or that had pictures of
other people's children in it then it
would have been redacted out right thank
you councillor mainland please
um i'm totally inv in favor of this um
this um
application one of the representations
uh that i noted was about antisocial
behavior within using the principal and
entrance when the actual building isn't
in use i was just wondering whether
maybe a shutter or something could be
put to
alleviate any worries about
people using that when it's not in use
i'm trying i'm trying to find which
entrance you're looking it's the new
it's the principal entrance the new one
i think it's set back by 1.5 meters
i'll just have a look at the elevations
my concern without any condition is that
this is
i don't know um at the stage of
how the applicant would take to that and
i'd also have concerns about what that
would look like in terms of um roller
shutters can have quite a hostile
appearance um within an area and it also
wasn't considered necessary last time
and so therefore i'd have to say is it
is it necessary to grant planning
permission
i i'd probably say noted suggestion but
i'd probably say in this instance we
wouldn't we wouldn't wish to see that um
added in
thank you okay so it has been proposed
in seconded that um permission be
granted in line with officer
recommendation uh we'll take that vote
if members happy to support that motion
can indicate now please
make that decision unanimous and that
permission is
granted so that concludes um business
under agenda item
six gender item seven is urgent business
i haven't been notified of any urgent
business so
with that we will then close the meeting
and thank you everybody for your
contributions tonight